[Music]
stacy's in austin texas hi stacy how are
you
hi can you all hear me okay sure what's
up
great um thanks so much for taking my
call i really enjoy listening to both of
you i feel like i'm having a fangirl
moment so
um
okay so
the simple question is
we have we've had a wake-up call in july
and or actually june
and we've tallied everything and we've
started we're on baby step two it is
just a really daunting number
um without our mortgage we own a home
without our mortgage we have a hundred
and seventy thousand dollars in debt
that's
you name it mostly credit cards and
student loans and some car payments and
how much do you owe on your cars
uh i owe 15 000 on mine my monthly
payment is 260. my husband owes 31 000
on his and his car payment is 600.
i recently sold a much bigger more
expensive car and downsides but was
afraid to pay all cash for it
um
so i cut my money that was before you
had the wake-up call
well kind of the beginning of it and
then it's a family car we have a
four-year-old son um
and
i just was like gosh we put the most
miles on my car so i just wanted it to
be something really reliable and safe
and
um
what are your two cars just tell me what
the two models are in year
sure i have a 2011 um
lexus rx 350 that's the 260 a month
and my husband drives a
dave i'm interested if you'll know this
one it's a 2014 chevy ss but it has a
hennessy supercharger in it oh yeah
and it's recently been re-tuned and it's
a it's a beast anyways those are our two
cars great gas mileage not uh yeah
all right so what's your household
income
um
we make over 200 000 we net 12 000 a
month um i i have a nice base salary but
also earn commissions so that's our low
end and some months we make more than
that my husband's salary is set and he's
an i.t
okay so we have a big shovel we're just
so your question is what
well
so i hate the amount of debt we have um
85 000 a year for two years and you're
out of debt
that's
i could do it i don't know if my
husband's
you know wanting to sacrifice so
ultimately
ultimately we're not in a home that we
want to be in forever we do want to move
to the northeast it's just a dream that
we've had
so
you know what the problem with that is
what you're going to go with you go in
the northeast yeah i know you're going
to go with you
and your husband who doesn't want to
sacrifice is going to go with you
no
you can't run from this
yeah the two the two of you in your
relationship and you the two of you as a
team have to stare this beast down
yeah and the beast is in your mirror
yeah you don't have a math problem you
got a me problem
yep
so that's where we start
and when he and
when the two of you call me back and say
we are truly sick and tired of being
sick and tired we're not going to
rationalize about a freaking
four-year-old needing a car to ride in
that's a certain kind of car called a
lexus
we're not gonna rationalize about
driving a muscle car when we're like a
grown man with children and can't pay
his bills we're not going to rationalize
and run to the northeast and pay all
this off with the equity from our home
and never have faced the fact that we
wouldn't pay a price to win in the
mirror you guys when you're ready to do
that you're ready to do anything you're
not you don't have to do any of these
things mathematically you can keep the
cars
but you can't keep the lifestyle and you
can't keep the wishy-washy i sort of
kind of want to do this stuff
not and get out of debt yeah not get out
of that
there's only one way you're going to get
out of debt is you guys have substantial
change in your view of money your view
of stuff your due of acquisition your
due of what gives you peace your view of
those things when you change those
things that's transformation
and you this debt will just evaporate in
two years when you do that
you'll be on my stage in here screaming
i'm debt free
i'd love to be stacy let me ask you a
quick question couple of credit cards
what's your monthly payments your
minimums that you're paying on these
credit cards give me a couple i'm just i
broke our debt down because i'm i'm the
geek um so
the consumer debt is 94 000 and we pay 2
000 a month on just consumer debt um i
called consumer debt everything but the
cars and his student loan by the way
it's all consumer data yeah it's all i
get i get you this is just how i broke
it down i really so
here's what you need to hear you guys
need to say this to each other out loud
we make 200 000 a year and we couldn't
even choose to live on that
i know that's what credit card nationals
for credit card debt if we don't change
yeah you're gonna be bankrupt you're
gonna be the bankrupt rich
people the reason i ask you this
question stacy is because you started
off the call going it feels
insurmountable but if you were to just
fix the car situation that's 860 bucks a
month a couple of credit cards you're
quickly over a thousand dollars a month
that would be free to then put towards
the student loans and with your income
what dave is saying you could get out of
this thing quick i just don't know that
you believe that you guys can get out of
this as quick as we believe you can well
200 minus 85 is not a bad month to live
on that's 115.
i know
yeah
not counting taxes but still i mean it's
still that's the big numbers but you
guys
i don't think my husband's willing to do
that but my husband is willing to move
to the northeast sell the house and pay
off all the debt with that with the
with the uh windfall you get from
selling a house in this world that we
live in today because he's going to make
a ton of money you can do that if you
want to do it but i predict this will
crop back up because you've never dealt
with you
he's never dealt with him and as a
couple we've never dealt with we need a
common vision for our home
the people with our last name
as for me and my house
we need a common vision and you all
don't have that your only common vision
is you spend like you're in congress
and it's killing you girl you're
breaking my heart
so i that's my challenge to y'all
lovingly as kindly as i can
be not conformed to this world
but be transformed by the renewing
of your mind live like no one else so
that later you can live and give
like no one else no discipline seems
pleasant at the time
but it yields
a harvest
of righteousness
this is what's in your future one way or
the other
you're either gonna decide or somebody's
gonna decide for you later
this is the ramsey show